So from our last two quizzes, we now have
developed a new expression for total money
earned by Grant. Instead of money from
wipers, we have 36w, where w is the amount
that each set of wipers cost. And instead
of money earned from nozzles, we have 11 times
2n, where n is equal to the amount that a
person pays for one nozzle. Now when I
look at this term 11 times 2n, it looks a little
bit complicated to me, definitely more
complicated than 36w does. Can you think
of a simpler way to write 11 times 2n?
Now, there are a ton of different ways that we
can write 11 times 2n and come up with a
mathematically equivalent expression, but
I would prefer that we try to come up with
a simpler way to write this. So, if you
have an idea of how to do that, please
type it into this box right here.